[Music]
hi everyone i'm javier luraski and today
i'm super excited to talk to you about
using pins with javascript and python
but why like you're probably already
aware that r is a pretty great
programming language
for data science so why should we care
well let me show you something there was
a survey
created by stack overflow that shows
that the top five programming languages
that are the most popular are javascript
html with css
sql python and java this happens to be
the programming languages that basically
run the software in the world
now r is not there it's uh it has 5.7
awareness compared to 67.7 percent
awareness of javascript
so the likelihood of you having to
interpret with javascript
or having to color collaborate with
someone that loves javascript or
python or sql is quite high
so how can we get art to interpret with
these programming languages
and for us as our data scientists to
collaborate with others
and that's what i want to explore on
this talk but let me give you some more
context
rather than talking about technologies
let's talk about a
fictional team that is working on
something
and this team is composed by three
members the first one is data scientist
darla
many of you will you know feel familiar
with her
because she happens to love r r is her
main programming language
language she's very into data science
and she's very very competent with the
tools she knows and love
like the tidy verse or tidy models or
even vase
r or you know other packages from the
art community
there's uh one more character that we'll
introduce which is
graphics greg now graphics greg comes
from a background on design
and he loves using javascript there is
no way that
you know like greg is going to learn how
to use
r and that's not necessarily bad r is
great for data science but like
greg loves doing uh static websites and
you know like helping people with their
design
so really the skills that he needs are
css html and javascript and he's very
competent with that
and there's one more person that you
know perhaps exemplifies
the python community and this would be
machine learning monica
monica likes to do machine learning with
things like network analysis and deep
learning
and she happens to love python she might
be familiar
with r but really she is really into
python and it's really hard to convince
her
to do otherwise so the problem that we
have at hand is
a pretty you know common problem which
is we live in a world where not everyone
speaks the same language
not everyone speaks r so let's try to
solve this problem
from the perspective of darla which is
our data scientist who loves r
what can darla do to get us closer to
collaborating with greg and monica
so a lot of the times what uh darla does
on her day today
is analyzing files and she has them in
front of her
she has different files perhaps we can
call them data frames
and you know she usually you know like
tidies them
you know like analyzes them shares them
and creates shiny applications on our
markdown out of them
and you know like it's it would be it
wouldn't be really acceptable for
darla to ask greg or monica to have to
learn r
or to install r in our studio to really
collaborate with her
so in her mind what she's thinking is
like well if i can
share the basic building block which is
the data set right that she's working on
if i could share that with greg and
monica i have a better chance of
convincing her
convincing them of collaborating with me
so what she's going on her mind is
thinking
well how can i share these data frames
in technologies like
github or kaggle or our studio connect
to kind of like help greg and monica
reuse my data sets without having to
install r
and you know there's actually great news
for many of you that are already
familiar
with this particular problem which is
darla knowing that she's a competent
data scientist
knows that there's a package called pins
which we've been developing
in the art community for the last year
and a half and allows her to do
tasks like this allows her to retrieve
data and upload data into the cloud
so what is the pins package as a quick
recap well first of all the pins package
allows you to get
a remote resource into your local
machine
so say if you have like a remote url
with a csv file
you can create a local cache on your
machine very easily
also once you're connected to those
remote services like kaggle or github
or rstudio connect you can also search
those services for data sets that are
interesting to you
all within the pins package and last but
not least and especially
important for this particular problem
that we're trying to solve
is the pins package allows you to share
data sets
in different cloud providers like google
kaggle azure
android studio connect and uh you can do
that quite easily and this is something
that darla is already familiar with she
knows that she can share
data sets with other uh colleagues
that also use r underpins package
now how does this work well the pins
package is actually quite simple you
install it from cran you load the
library
and then you can ask it to pin a
data set either an r object or a remote
resource or a local file
into your local board which is what
we're doing in this particular example
and then after you pin that resource
locally you can use your favorite tools
to process it like in this
case we're just reading a remote json
file
saving it locally and then using json
light to read it
now that's the simple use case of the
pins package to bring things into your
local machine
but you can also use the pins package to
push things out of your local machine
and what darla could do here potentially
is
register a board which is a concept from
the pins package
the uh the board that she registers
could be you know github
digitalocean google cloud rstudio kaggle
uh azure or aws s3
and she can basically push the data set
from something as simple of
an array of ten numbers by saying pin 1
to 10
name equals numbers and then board
equals say google cloud whatever
and the data set that she has locally
can be pushed to be shared to those
particular services
and if she needs to get it back at any
point in time she can just say
pin get and the data set will come back
from those services into her local
machine again
you can do a little bit more complex
stuff like you can say
suppose that you're collaborating in a
image
processing project and you have imagenet
you can retrieve a smaller version of
imagenet called tiny imagenet by saying
pin this remote resource locally into my
local machine
and we'll call it imagenet and then what
you can do is you can also say
oh give me back imagenet and now i want
to push it
to perhaps toggle because maybe you did
some
cleaning of the data or some processing
so all of these are tasks that the pins
package supports
including finding you can just say pin
find and it will find the
different data sets that are available
in the different boards
so this is quite great and if we think
about it from
darla's point of view we're pretty close
to the space that greg and monica are
interested
we've moved our data sets from our local
machine to the cloud
but then again then we have the question
that in this case nelson
nelson baguette is asking and he's
saying he's thinking
wait this is a pretty great package for
for our community why can't we just do
the same from
javascript or python rather than having
to be downloading random json files or
csv files and figuring out
authentication and permissions why can't
we just have the same code being used in
python
or javascript and sure enough like the
whole point of this talk is for me to
introduce you to a new project pins js
which is a re-implementation of the pins
r package into javascript
that supports python as well this
enables you to use
pins from technologies like app web
browser with html
or web applications running node.js or
even python
and the way that we accomplish this is
basically by
re-implementing the functionality
available on r in javascript
and this allows you to interpret with r
so if someone shares a data set from r
you can then quite easily get the data
set from javascript or python
which is quite great and even push data
sets from python
and javascript back into cloud service
providers
so how does this look like well here we
have some html
code it's quite simple it's declaring
that uh this particular html file needs
the pins library and also is running
within the browser environment
and then we're basically just defining
some javascript callbacks to
use pins in this particular case we are
saying board register to register a
local board
and then we're creating a data set which
the data set is just the number 42
and we're saving it in a local board and
then we're retrieving the value and then
we're
printing it into the web page
as a inside a div which is our result
and you know we can complicate this a
little bit more rather than just
creating one data set
we can create multiple data sets in
javascript say using a for loop from one
to ten we'll push those
data sets into the uh into the local
board and then we can search them
and create uh perhaps a page table on
javascript that shows us
all the different uh pins that we have
stored which you can see
on on the top right and we can even go a
little bit step
further and you know if you're really
into like state-of-the-art javascript
applications you can use a library
called babel
which allows you to transpile modern
javascript into
compatible javascript and you can make
use of perhaps the new pipe operator
to get the iris json file using
pins and then pipe it into the
function that basically reads this data
set from
json and then creating a data table with
the entire iris data set
and that's what we see on the top right
so again you're just using
javascript to different degrees using
pins in the way that you would expect to
use
javascript and similar for python if you
want to use
pins from python all you have to do is
run
pip install from with the url that
uh that is hosting the pins.js python
library
and then you import the library with
import pins and then you create pins
with pins pin
number 42 and then the board where
you're storing this data into
you can also do things like retrieving a
pin obviously from either the local
board or a remote board
and then you can also find and to figure
out which are the pins that are
available to you
which in this case is just the number
that we just pinned and the iris data
set
all right so this gives us kind of like
a pretty broad overview of how the pins
package works but we want to see it in
action on a real
kind of like use case so let's think
about this uh
darla greg and monica get together over
a launch
and they're trying to figure out which
is the most important character
of the last book in game of thrones so
you know like they have some insight
that perhaps you know like
either daenerys or maybe tyrion are the
most important characters but they
can't really figure out exactly which
one is the most important one
so darla being the competent data
scientist that we know she is
she just after launch she gets back to
her office and you know
launches the her our
instance and runs the pins
library to find out if there's any
interesting data sets on the kaggle
service and sure enough she finds that
kaggle
has at least three data sets one
containing all the scripts from the
hbo series the other one the subtitles
and the third data set contains the
actual books
from you know with all the dialogues and
content
from uh from game of thrones so sure
enough this looks interesting
she uses pin get to get this particular
data set and finds
out that there is five books five files
one for each book
she loads the first book using pin get
and the head of that particular file
and she finds that sure enough the file
starts with a game of thrones
book of one song of ice and fire great
she has the data
so what she can do next is something
that you're pretty familiar with
she can use tools like deployer or tidy
text
or even string r with regular
expressions
whatever skills you already know and you
that you are learning about during this
conference
basically darla makes use of those
skills
to transform the data set from raw text
into a tidy table that contains the
proper relationships between characters
she finds out for instance that one of
the first interactions is
adam are brown with jamie lannister and
that with a weight of three and maybe
the way that daryl accomplished this was
by
parsing each sentence and extracting the
characters from each sentence and
figuring out just how they are connected
so yeah sure enough she creates a
beautiful data set which contains most
of the interactions
and she reports back and tells greg and
monica is like hey i think that on the
fifth book there's a lot of
you know like relationships between jon
snow and
also tyrion and other characters so
check it out
and what she does is she shares the data
set using pins by registering
a board in the s3 aws
service and she shares that this cleanup
data set with
greg and monica and uh what is great is
that
you know when greg hears the news he's
like super excited because
greg is not that much interested into
doing data science but he's very
interested in creating
intuitive visualizations that can really
help us understand
how data behaves so she looks at darla's
data set and you know like
just wants to boot his sublime editor or
visual studio code or whatever he uses
and you know like loads the pins package
and then retrieves the data set from s3
and as you can see he's accomplishing
this with just two lines of code
he gets the data and then he loads it
and she he is
good to go so then he thinks about it
and he's like well maybe i can use
d3 which is a modern data visualization
library
available in javascript to kind of like
create a
kind of like a network visualization of
how the all the relationship of these
characters looks like
and sure enough he uses his skill to
create this
particular graph which
looks actually quite compelling and
interesting uh but
as you can see on the graph this graph
that graphic greg created there's
kind of like two major components
there's one component on the top
kind of like surrounding jon snow with
other characters like
theon greg joy and also stannis
baratheon but there's also like another
component
of characters surrounding daenerys
targaryen like
tyrion lannister and cersei and you know
it's interesting because
this is just like a different type of
skills
that is super you know like great
looking intuitive
that anyone can understand uh you know
perhaps is interactive and it really
prompts other people to
understand this data set with the
scripts on with the skills of from greg
and
darla combined and sure enough like
monica is also super excited about this
she looks at the data center and he's
like wow
i really need to get into this but like
i what goes on her mind is like i really
want to know exactly
who's the most important character is it
reader is it jon snow or is it daenerys
like i
i want to know with a numeric with a
numeric value which is the most
important character and sure enough with
pins she can
uh now load the pins library and
retrieve this data set that darla
carefully created
and load it into her python session
and load the characters and again with
three lines of code like she's ready to
go
she can kind of like do some more
analysis and
taking the data set from darla and the
inspiration from greg
it really pops on her head and she
figures out that maybe she shouldn't use
some graph
processing so she loads the network x
library which
uh can uh can allow her to do
graph processing over graph data sets
and she basically uses a concept called
degree of centrality
which you know the way that she
interpreted and interprets this concept
is like if she can't find the degree of
centrality
of this particular graph of game of
thrones characters
that could also imply which is the most
central character
in the roles of the different in the
different books that are
available and sure enough after running
her script
and doing some magic she finds out that
on the first book
king stark is the most important
character but on the fifth book
the race between jon snow and daenerys
are pretty close
jon snow seems to be a bit of more of a
central character with a score of 0.19
while daenerys targaryen has a score of
0.18
so again you know she finds out that
perhaps objectively jon snow is the most
important character in the entire season
and the series or at least on the last
on the last book
but honestly more importantly what we
just realized here is that
we found out a way for three people with
three different technologies and three
very different set of skills to
collaborate together using technologies
that they all love
and common libraries that they can reuse
to better collaborate and
tackle bigger more complex data science
problems
so i'm really excited to see what you do
with this new library if you need more
information please
visit pinsjs.github.io
i want to say that this is a community
library that we've been developing
and it definitely needs the help of the
community to extend support
for more boards beyond s3
local boards and rstudio connect to you
know boards like kaggle and github
and i also want to say thanks to people
that have been involved in this project
like
natalia stefanova and michael calligan
thank you so much for listening to this
talk and i hope that you are ready to
start sharing your data sets